Do you like being tickled?
First, you laugh a lot.
It’s uncontrollable but funny.
Then you laugh so hard
that your abs hurt
(Frantically laughing)
Okay, stop.
But what if
the tickling doesn't stop
for 24 hours?
Could you be tickled to death?
There are two types of tickling.
The most common is
That's when someone touches
parts of your body repeatedly,
causing you to laugh.
The other type of tickling is
That's where a light touch on your skin
causes a tickling sensation
but not laughter.
The most sensitive areas
are your stomach,
sides,
armpits,
feet,
and neck.
And the reason you can’t tickle yourself,
it's that there is no element of surprise.
Your brain knows
that the sensation is coming.
But research has shown
that those with schizophrenia
can tickle themselves
because their brain can’t differentiate
between self-generated
and externally generated touches.
So, how much tickling
could the human body handle?
"Don't do that, it tickles ok!"
You tried to avoid it,
but you’re now being tickled.
Even the thought of it makes you giggle.
You know that feeling.
Sometimes you’re laughing,
but it doesn’t mean
that you are enjoying it.
Scientists from
the University of California
found that tickling doesn’t create
the same laughter someone
gets from a funny joke.
It’s just an outward illusion.
"Ohh, that tickles!"
Being tickled stimulates
your hypothalamus,
the part of your brain
that controls your emotional reactions.
It’s also where
the physiological reaction to an attack
or a threat is activated.
So when you laugh from being tickled,
you have an automatic
emotional response.
But the body movements you make
mimic those of individuals
in severe pain.
A prolonged tickle
would be extremely unpleasant.
So, you might want to stop at this point.
After one hour of non-stop giggles,
your core would be extremely sore.
It would be the best workout of your life
and the nastiest one.
They say laughter is the best medicine.
But, in this case,
I beg to differ.
Okay, you've been tickled
for 10 hours now.
It's pure torture.
As a matter of fact,
tickling has been used
in sinister ways in the past.
During the Han Dynasty,
in the 3rd century B.C.E.,
the Chinese used it as torture
because the victim would suffer,
but it didn’t leave any marks.
Sorry, but this last stretch
will not be pleasant.
The constant laughter you’ve had
for 15 hours
could lead you to pass out.
Fainting is caused
by a temporary drop in blood pressure.
Your brain doesn't get
the blood flow it needs,
and you lose consciousness.
It could cause you both mental
and physical harm.
So please,
don't try this at home,
with yourself or your friends.
Okay, by the time you reach
the end of this challenge,
you’d have lost control of your body.
You wouldn’t be able to regulate
your breathing
and you would be very stressed.
You could have asphyxia,
a brain aneurysm
or a heart attack.
Yeah, so to answer your question,
yes, you can be tickled to death.
"Get me out of this now!"
If tickling isn't your thing,
well, how about dancing?
Think you could twist
and shake for 24 hours?
Alright then, let's party.
We'll see what that challenge brings
on another episode of